so we've had some areas with big  thunderstorms a third of an inch of rain  in the northern end of the valley and  look at these cells that are forming  again down around sandy valley and on  the backside of the spring mountains and  riding right up again towards the  pahrump valley where we've already had  some good rain now we had a couple of  little cells early this morning around  the southwest part of the valley didn't  drop much rain at all and we're gone but  we're starting to see more cells now  down south of town most of these are  coming out of northwest arizona  and they are popping and dropping some  very heavy rain with flood warnings that  are already in effect for parts of  mohave county you can see these areas  they will be in effect until 2 45. the  larger areas of green are flash flood  watches for most of western arizona a